In the year 400 in one.
The Prince of Persia Cyrus
who is a younger son and had been
the the recent.
Recently succeeded king of Persia artic circus sees his older brother was in
power.
Cyrus had always been ambitious for achieving the
job of Shah in Persia and his mother had worked in his behalf but it hadn't paid
off.
He was not prepared to accept the verdict and so he set out in the year 400 and
one to launch a scheme that would bring him to the throne of Persia and his
scheme was to hire.
A good sized army of Greek mercenaries and to trick them into becoming the army
that would defeat the army of his brother artic circuses and make him king.
As it turned out one of the men who joined up on that expedition was in Athenian
cavalryman by the name of Xenophon and he left an account of that experience in
a work that in court is called in Greek.
The analysis which means that the march back but it's the story of how this body
of a turned out to be roughly 10000 Greek hop like mercenaries marched into the
heart of the Persian Empire defeated the Army of the great king.
But in the process Prince Cyrus himself was killed.
And since the whole point of the expedition was to make him king there wasn't
any point any longer and the great question.
I've told you about this earlier in the semester.
What should these 10000 Greeks do they end up after their generals are put to
death by treachery to elect new generals and to fight their way out of the
empire back to the Black Sea which was the easiest way for them to get home and
then to do whatever it was they would do.
It was a very important event because and I think Xenophon's account of it was
very very important because it planted in the minds of many Greeks a new notion
that the vast powerful wealthy empire of the Persians was remarkably vulnerable
and that it was an epoch.
It was possible and many thought highly desirable for the Greeks to turn the
tables on the Persians to invade Persia and to take from it to to subdue it and
to take from it the vast wealth that the Persians had.
And we shall see down through the years of the fourth century.
Different speakers will come out and speak or write urging that the Greeks do
exactly this.
I Socrates the Athenian teacher of rhetoric was the foremost figure who kept
seeking some body who would undertake this chore.
One of the reasons that he gave for it more than once was that Greece was
suffering and of course had been for some time from poverty produced by war and
most particularly by civil wars between Democrats and oligarchs that became more
and more common in the fourth century and his solution was if you need money
steal it and so take it from the Persians and that would put an end to the
troubles.
Well of course none of the Greek city states was capable of establishing
leadership in Greece during the period we're studying now so that it could carry
out.
Socrates wishes so he turned to a man that the rest of the Greeks regarded as or
many of the Greeks regarded as a barbarian the king of Macedon Philip and urged
him to take on that course.
And apparently whether it was a Socrates or simply the idea itself.
Philip himself did intend to do exactly that to conquer the Persian Empire but
he was killed before he could do it.
And the job was left to his quite young son Alexander who in fact accomplished
that.
But we're looking down the road.
Let's go back to for one.
And there we see this expedition of ten thousand Greeks accomplishing what I
mentioned to you that there could be ten thousand Greek hob lights available for
such a purpose.
I think as a consequence of the Peloponnesian War it shows us how much that war
had helped to uproot people and to impoverish many of them so that the idea of
becoming a mercenary soldier for a Persian prince was attractive enough to take
them away from home something that would have been less likely in the prosperous
years before the Peloponnesian War.
Well of course
that aside that's a kind of it is a kind of a sideshow it doesn't very much
affect what is happening to the Greek cities on the coast of Asia Minor who
remain the issue as to what will happen.
Remember these were
under Athenian control during the Peloponnesian War and when the war was over
they were taken over in many cases by Lt.
Sander what was to happen to them.
Ultimately still had to be decided because the king of Persia claimed that
territory still for his own.
The Spartans had really agreed to that in the treaties they made with the great
king during the Peloponnesian War.
But now like Sandra I didn't see any reason for carrying out those promises and
so there was at the very least conflict.
And of course what the cities would have liked best of all was to achieve
autonomy for themselves and they claimed that and regarded the rule either by
Persian or by Spartan as improper and something to be resisted.
Well to suffer is the strap of the region of Libya and to the west the ones that
included the Greek cities attacked those cities which he claimed for the great
king but which cities were holding out those cities in turn because the great
menace to them for the moment was Persian turned to Sparta the great Victoria's
power and asked the Spartans to help
and in the year four hundred three ninety nine the Spartans sent an army under a
general by the name of Cimarron who recruited about six thousand of those ten
thousand men who had marched into the Persian Empire and who still saw its
service as mercenaries rather than go home to poverty plus about 5000 or so
Peloponnesian.
All of the overseas activities of the Spartans in these years include
practically no Spartans.
They are just too short of troops to be risking them in overseas ventures so
they use their Peloponnesian allies.
They sometimes use mercenaries and they
they also use some of these folks.
I told you about the last time who were neither this nor that.
This is the ones that they used on these campaigns are the ones that we are
calling neo demo days people who had been hell lots but who were liberated and
permitted to fight for the Spartans and the notion of sending neo demo days
overseas to fight was very attractive to the Spartans because it got them out of
Laconia.
For one thing and provided them with soldiers as well.
So that kind of army is the one that Cibrian is now using to fight against the
Persians who just a few years ago had been the allies of the Spartans for
control of the Greek cities of Asia Minor.
Now meanwhile we have to turn our attention excuse me to the sea and especially
to the island of Cyprus.
It's a Persian possession but on that island there are some cities that have a
degree of autonomy one of them.
It has as its king a man called Vargas and he is very ambitious for himself and
for the Cypriots.
And so he is eager
to fight against the Spartans on behalf of presumably on behalf of the great
king although his motives are not made clear by our sources.
Reasonable Guesses that he may have hoped by achieving something great for the
great king he might receive back thanks from the great king in whatever form you
can imagine it might be allowing him to rule over Cyprus it might mean to give
him wealth.
Who knows but also on the island of Cyprus where he had taken refuge was the
Athenian Admiral Conan who had been one of the admirals at the final defeat and
Eagle's part of my he had escaped from that battle and had not gone home to
Athens he felt that the air there would not be healthy for somebody who lost the
entire fleet at this part of mine.
And so he went to evangelists who who took good care of it.
Conan was a great sailor.
One of the very most distinguished admirals in Greek history and he too now
continued his feeling that Sparta was the enemy.
So he joined evaporates and urging the great king to build a navy which would
then defeat the Spartan Navy which would by itself rid Asia of the menace of
Sparta and be a great thing for the Persians CONAN I suspect had some other
hopes out of this activity which in fact will come to fruition.
I'll tell you about them in due course.
Well so now you have the Spartans have their fleet out there and the King agrees
and he starts building a fleet of his own which will ultimately be a very large
one.
Indeed some 300 ships and the King puts Conan on in charge of that fleet which
is smart in a way because Cohen is a great Admiral maybe not so smart.
If you look at what Conan is really up to
in the face of these activities the Spartans decided to raise the ante and they
sent an expedition into Asia Minor Tiburon had not done very well.
And after about a year the Spartans replaced him with another general by the
name of their syllabus who does better but there is no decisive victory out
there the war is dragging on.
And so they choose to send the new king just the.
Who is the son of ages.
Who whose characteristics are among other things that he was born lame.
He probably would not have been allowed to live.
Had he not come from the royal family.
But he did.
And he grew to be an ambitious aggressive Spartan king who I suspect I mean
cheap psychology.
When you have a handicap like that in a society which values physical valour and
strength and military success so highly as the Spartans did you're twice as
aggressive and twice as ambitious as an ordinary Spartan.
In any case that was the way a destiny is turned out to be.
Another interesting thing about it just layers is that he had been the the tenth
mate of life Sandor and it's hard to believe that bystander could ever have
achieved the eminence that he did.
The command that was given to him had he not been a friend of the young man that
people looked to as the next king or possibly the next king.
But as he had to adjust the layers had was used as you being much younger man
than life Sander he seemed to be deferential and everything was OK.
And so he was very keen on doing what the Spartans did which was to send a
display is out with a new expedition to win the war against the Persians out
there just like this.
It is plain had extremely lofty plans for himself and for this expedition and
the way the the the way the expedition worked just lays chose to leave with his
fleet from the town of Alice which is located in biosphere does anybody
recognize the name and think why it just later should have wanted to leave from
Alice.
That's right.
Agamemnon took off for the Trojan War at Alice.
And you remember how the legend goes.
Shit the winds were against the Greeks they wouldn't let the ships get away and
they asked him a holy man to tell them what the gods were up to and the gods
said Well they you can't go until you sacrifice your daughter your little
daughter.
If a denier
to the gods for that purpose.
So Agamemnon did and the winds relented and Agamemnon would pay the price when
he got back from Troy but it is precisely that the Greek fleet against the
barbarian against the non Greeks the most important ones and all of their
legends namely the Trojans.
It was at all hours that they left and Agamemnon excuse me I just alas wanted to
bring that to the my he was the new Agamemnon and he was not leading a Spartan
or a fleet against the Persians he was the spokesman for the Greeks he was the
leader of the Greeks revenge thing that original offense whatever that might be.
He was trying to make the case for a pan hellenic motive for what was absolutely
a strictly Spartan one and raising himself to a legendary level practically.
Well that turned out to be a mistake because the seasons happened at that moment
to be as far as we can tell led by a faction that was very hostile to the
Spartans so as adjust the place as people were setting up the altars for
sacrifices before they took off along the road came a thieving army knocked over
all of the altars and asked them who the hell invited him in to be OCA in the
first place to get the hell out of there grossly insulting adjusts the place and
forcing him to skulk out of this not in the grand way that he had imagined.
This turned out to be very significant but just the place took it personally.
He didn't like that and I suppose.
Well never mind.
It's about to make a bad joke.
Let it go.
And it had an enormous impact on him because for the rest of his life.
I just Elias will be hostile to thieves and when he could he would promote a
policy of attacking thieves of trying to defeat it to subjected to Sparta and a
whole piece of Spartan foreign policy which was to be very costly and damaging
to Sparta was the result of a just delays his attempt at vendetta against the
seaman's
well.
He goes to Asia and begins to encounter the Persians he does pretty well as
always Greek hop lights if they can get the Persians to fight them in a nice
flat field beat them.
And he did that on several occasions but he was never able to bring a large
force of Persians to battle so that he could really destroy a good chunk of
Persian power in the region so that the victories were not decisive they could
not win the war.
He could win the battles but you couldn't win the war at least he didn't.
Meanwhile things turned round against the Spartans of from the side that you
might expect that is to say from the see
Konate with the Persian fleet sailed against the very important island of Rhodes
and captured it brought it back to took it away from the Spartans in any case
where the Spartans went.
You will remember they established oligarchic governments and in this case the
victorious Athenian Admiral removed the oligarchic government and in its place
there rose up a democracy.
I'm sure the great king didn't care what kind of a regime it was for the moment.
He just wanted to get rid of the Spartans which he did.
But it was of course on the greek scene it was a great defeat for the Spartans
and it was a challenge to the Spartans it was obvious that Conan at least and
who knew what might happen from.
On the part of other Greeks were going to resist Spartan power and Spartan
aggressiveness and that if he wanted to come back them he would have to have a
navy and the Spartans set out to increase their navy to meet this challenge.
And just to look ahead a few years I think we need to at this moment
it was that Spartan fleet that Conan defeated thoroughly and decisively a few
years later in three ninety four at the Battle of Coney dogs and which really
puts an end for considerable time.
The whole idea of Sparta fighting at sea entirely it really means that.
That.
Approach remember we were talking last time about different the three different
possibilities that the Spartans had to choose among.
And they chose for a while this thoroughly aggressive one overseas that's out.
Now if you're been defeated at sea you don't have a navy that can challenge your
opponents.
You can't do it.
And as a matter of fact that will not be very much longer.
When events in Greece compel them to withdraw their army under a just alliance
and bring them back home and no Spartan army ever goes back to Asia again that
we're looking ahead but that the action that caused that was the victory at
Canada's
now of course with the Spartans being defeated in that part of the world the
Greek cities that have been under Spartan rule now typically rebel against the
Spartan rule.
And we must imagine that for a few years there are really quite confused
conditions in Asiatic Greece.
Some places may have continued to be under Spartan rule some may have continued
to be under Persian rule no doubt about it some of them became autonomous.
We just don't know what the numbers were.
And there could have been mixtures of things going on too.
I make that point because when later on final settlement is produced there.
It is imposed upon a condition of confusion rather than simply overthrowing a
single thing that was characteristic across the board.
Still many of those towns as I say did return to Persian rule as well.
That's the situation for which leads us to the next great event in holiness
history across the board.
The currency and war as it is called which breaks out in three ninety five and
runs down to three eighty seven six so-called because the bulk of the fighting
on land was around the city of Khans but it was it was a war that engaged all of
the major cities of Greece right around its core and its center.
I think the fair a fair way to see it is the cause of that war was in its most
fundamental sense Sparta tyrannical behavior towards the other Greek cities
which produces a variety of reactions.
Let me remind you of some and tell you about some others that we haven't talked
about.
You remember there was these grievances that lingered from the end of the
Peloponnesian War when Spartan allies like Corinth and Thebes had been very
dissatisfied with the way the booty had been shared.
That came from the defeat of the Athenians.
And you remember those two cities were aggrieved also because the Spartans
ignored their wishes as to what should happen to Athens and went their own way.
There too.
I think I mentioned as well that in all contexts with non Spartans in this
period the Spartans seem to be very arrogant very hard to get along with and
they certainly inspire considerable unhappiness and discontent.
Those things you know about now in FORERO To the Spartans
launched a war against the polis of Eilis located up in the northwestern corner
of the Peloponnese.
Olympia is included in that area just to help you fix it in your mind.
Now the Spartans call upon their allies to join them in this expedition as is
their right.
According to the traditional rules of the game in the Peloponnesian league
Thebes and Corinth refuse to send their contingents.
That is practically
an act of rebellion against the Spartans.
It's a violation of their treaty agreements and it shows you how much irritation
there existed between them and the whole the whole campaign seemed to these
states very annoying because why were these Spartans attacking Ellis partly
because they had a continuing debate conflict with them about a border town.
It's the old stuff but also I think as an act of revenge because the aliens had
been disloyal during the Peloponnesian War during the peace of Nicky after for
twenty one Ellis was one of the four democracies that joined up in this new
separate league that ended up fighting against the Spartans for a period of time
in the great battle of Manzanita in which the very existence of Sparta was at
issue.
Ellis was on the side of the enemies of Sparta so that was why the Spartans
suddenly decided to attack them and the Allies didn't think that was right.
The ones who were discontented in any case
so that's in the background and all these other irritations that I have
mentioned.
But it wasn't enough because even if you were as mad as you could be at the
Spartans and determined to try to undo their effort at hegemony over the Greeks
there was no easy way to think of fighting them successfully.
All of these states that were discontented Thebes Carnes and as we will quickly
see Athens as well were isolated from each other they didn't belong to any
common activity and they all were not as strong enough individually to take on
the Spartans.
Moreover there was the problem.
If you wanted to fight these people it would require money and all of them were
short of funds for that purpose.
So the critical element necessary to create a coalition that could undertake a
war against Sparta
that decision was made by the Persians.
The king of Persia presumably although it very much looks like the new SAT
trapped in that region that to a to set traps in the western part of the Persian
Empire remember the one whose capital is at Sardi's in Libya and the one whose
capital or whose territory is along the helos Ponce and the Straits in general
find a basis our old friends run of bases from the Peloponnesian War and a new
set trap in Sardi's.
Both want this to happen and so they find a road in Greek and give him a batch
of money and send him to the Greek cities seeking out those factional leaders
who were known to be hostile to Sparta and offering to give them them some of
the money that he was carrying which was not in itself a vast amount and
certainly not enough to fight any war but was obviously a sign of good faith
saying the king of Persia and his sad traps in this region are against the
Spartans and would like for you to put an end to the things you don't like that
are happening in the Greek world and he will support you with his money.
That I think turned out to be an absolutely critical act.
He went out to a town I have not mentioned that belongs in the company of the
anti Spartan people at this point of course is our gods the traditional enemy of
Sparta running back at least into the 8th century and perhaps further than that
with who seemed to find themselves in a war with the Spartans at least once a
century and it looks like this is the time in the 4th century for them.
August is a democracy too and as you know that is a relevant fact.
Currency is not a democracy but they are so angry they want to play too and they
join up thieves again.
It's hard to tell what the government is it looks throughout this entire period
as oligarchy and democracy may well have been very close to one another so that
any time one faction or the other may have the upper hand and of course Athens
which is a democracy again.
Now the Athenians have been very very reluctant to do anything to annoy the
Spartans for very good reasons.
They have no navy they have no walls and they have no money so to buck the
Spartans would be an act almost of suicide because all the Spartans need to do
is come marching into Attica and they have no defense.
Up to now therefore they've been very very careful not to annoy.
In fact in four 0 2 when the sequence in the Corinthians refused to go to Ellis
with the Spartans the Athenians sent their force as they were required to do by
their treaty with the Spartans.
But the new situation changed things and Athens just as it did perhaps even more
than it did in other cities.
Now the great king the Persians were not the enemy the Persians were going to
support the war if they were ready to launch it against the.
The Spartans.
There was no war yet.
I should point out when this money is being handed out this is an effort to stir
up that kind of activity.
Of course the enemies of the policy referred to these these transfers of money
as bribes and there's no nothing in Greek practice or break Greek tradition to
reject the idea that some of these Persian coins ended up in the pockets of the
men that they were given to.
But I don't think we really should think of them as bribes.
Most of the money was used for the purpose for which it was intended to help
these leaders stir up support for a war against Sparta.
It was something they believed in anyway.
It was a source of their ability to carry out their wishes but as I say did.
The Greeks didn't think there was anything wrong with picking up a few bucks
along the way.
Now.
A war breaks out on the frontier between forces and local risk to towns in
central Greece both of which are quite close to Bosnia.
The land ruled by the thieves
the Spartans and I think this was probably well I'm pretty confident that it
was.
What this motivated by the Spartan unhappiness about Thebes.
The Spartans assist forces against locusts knowing that Thebes is allied to
locusts and that this would be.
They believed and hope a pretext for war.
This was their chance to get even with the seasons for all the things that the
seasons had done that irritated them since the war so Sparta invaded the OCA.
Their strategy to win this war was that they would invade beyond from two sides
one army coming from central Greece from the region of focus and Locus where
they were assisting the oceans and another army being sent up from the
Peloponnese itself.
They do finally meet in three ninety five at a town in western B ocean called
Halley arches where there is a battle and where by the way lies Sandor is killed
in the fighting and removed from the sea but even before that happened.
As it was clear that the Spartans meant to fight the sea the sea beans went to
Athens and asked the Athenians for help.
And of course they had a case that was very attractive.
First of all it certainly reminded the Athenians of the role Thebes had played
in liberating Athens by giving a home to thrash the bullies and his free
Athenians when they were in the position of defeating the thirty tyrants and
driving them out.
I have a feeling they didn't remind the Athenians about that little Congress
they had after the war in which they suggested that they destroy all the
Athenians and take away their land and turn the whole place into a great big
cattle farm.
I think they probably didn't remember to mention that but but they had that
reason.
But more important than that was what they were saying.
You have a chance now to escape from your bondage to the Spartans where the
Athenians certainly were and to re-establish yourself as an autonomous Polis
along with us and all the others who want to take away power from the Spartans
which they are abusing so terribly now the remarkable thing to me is that
Xenophon who very likely was their.
Reports that the Athenian Assembly voted unanimously in favor Well it's worth
pointing out of course that the number one advocate of doing that.
Of joining the rebellion against and against Sparta was threats of bullies.
The great hero of the time that certainly made a big difference and threats of
bullies had been one of the cautious leaders before who had been against getting
these Spartans mad because he knew Athens was in incompetent incompetent to
fight them now but with the Persian support and with the prospect of forming a
coalition against Sparta the strategic situation had changed and threats of
bullies now came out 100 percent for the war.
But unanimous vote in favor of the war.
I can't imagine the Athenian Assembly giving unanimous vote in favor of getting
a drink of water.
It's just so incredible to me so how do I explain.
Well I gotta make it up.
I think there was an overwhelming sentiment in favor.
Obviously the attractions were great but there were reasons to fear if you lose
the price could be very very high.
But I think what happened was that the emotion was so strong that at the moment
that once it was evident that there was a large majority in favor of the motion
nobody wanted to be seen as being against it.
It would have had the look of cowardice of a lack of patriotism and people in
these circumstances it has been my experience.
Hate to seem not to be going along when everybody is enthusiastically going in a
particular direction so that's how I interpret Xenophon's remarkable testimony.
But whatever whatever it is the truth of it.
What is clear is that great enthusiasm overwhelming majority.
They are prepared to fight for their true autonomy in the war to come.
So the Coalition is finally for Athens thieves.
Cars are gone.
Those are the main states on the mainland.
They'll do most of the fighting but it's worth pointing out
that there are other places that join too.
You'll be to the island to the east of Attica.
Not surprising.
They're so thoroughly influenced by the Athenians that's not a great surprise
but it's interesting that many a town up in the north of the Aegean on the child
cities see also joined in this anti Spartan coalition and likewise the region in
the West and not on the Ionian Sea of car Narnia.
Also join which I think suggests that there was quite a lot of anti Spartan
sentiments in the Greek world at this time which you know very often comes about
if any state seems to be too strong too too.
Too powerful too much of a threat to what everybody else wants.
People tend to cut it down.
Political scientists tend to formalize this into the notion of.
What you call it.
If you join up with the most powerful state it's called bandwagon.
What do they call bandwagon.
What do they call it if if you're against the balancing that's the worry.
Sorry I'm weak in my political science technology.
Yeah balancing is what's supposed to be the truth of the matter is that you
never can tell which way the state states will go in these situations.
There you are but in this case though I'm simply making the point that there was
a lot of hostility to Sparta out there and some people you wouldn't think of
joined in this.
But it's the big four that really matter and they do most of the fighting in the
war well.
There's no point in going through the war in great detail just a few highlights
I think need to be mentioned.
The largest highlight of all being how in the world is supposed to win this war.
What is the the the strategy on each side.
And it's remarkable how similar they are.
The Spartans want to gain control of the Isthmus of currents its currents and
mega especially so that they can get out into central Greece and defeat their
opponents individually and B O show for this evens and Atika for the Athenians
and currents of course right there in the Isthmus.
The other folks are there.
The big four want to push into the Peloponnese is where they can raise up the
rebellion of the
harlots and the pari oi oi and defeat the Spartans right there and strip away
their allies in the Peloponnese.
So each side basically has to gain control of the Isthmus and then move forward
to carry out the conclusion of the war in their favor.
And the bottom line is neither side is able to do it the bulk of the fighting
throughout the years of that war surround the city of Corinth.
Walls are put up by the Corinthians meant to keep the Spartans out.
They do so for a great chunk of time.
The Spartans can take part of the walls but they can't manage to take everything
into punch through.
And so for all these years that's what happens there are some big battles that
are fought this one and 394 soon after the beginning of the war at Noumea which
is located to the south of sea of currents.
It's a very big tough standard hop like battle both sides having strong armies
both sides fighting well and determinedly the Spartans technically winning.
It's one of those victories where you know who won because they put up the
trophy and they were able to collect their dead and the other guys had to ask
permission to come to collect their debt but it was another one of these
victories that did not have strategic consequences neither side had been able to
destroy the other.
Neither side could now advance into the region that they had to get to in order
to make a difference so that I think is the major story of that war.
There's another side.
Another.
Event in there that has interesting consequences for a future Greek warfare that
deserves mentioning at a certain point in that war the Athenians under an
extraordinary general by the name of difficulties had put together a force of
light armed troops not hot lights people without hot line armor and shields who
threw missiles at the other side.
Probably mainly slingers but they also would have been spear throwers throwers
not thrusters.
And Bowman.
And these guys could never confront the Phalanx in a normal way and they would
normally and having to be able to do much harm in an extraordinary way.
But.
That what was new was that a fix whities had trained them as a professional
force.
So they could move swiftly and together as a body in such a way as to be as
effective as it was possible for light on troops to be against and a phalanx.
And it happened that difficulties was able to maneuver a whole division of
Spartan soldiers in such a way that they got stuck.
In a dead end in a cool de sac and were absolutely victimized by difficulties
light armed forces and about 600 men making up this division of the Spartan army
called the division is called a.
You were wiped out and the Greek world was astonished by this because no such
thing had ever happened before.
And it led to the increased use of well-trained light armored infantry will play
a larger role.
They never replace the Phalanx as the major form of land warfare but they things
become more complicated in the fourth century as they have already begun to be
in the Peloponnesian War as you have different branches that are able to perform
more usefully than they were typically expected to do in the past.
I mean perhaps as big an event as any that occurred in that war was the event I
mentioned earlier Conan using the Persian fleet defeating the Spartan fleet at
the Battle of
anybody take a note.
It's just gone out of my mind can he does can he does it 394.
But what does he do.
CONAN takes his victorious fleet sails back to Athens the Athenians have already
begun the process of rebuilding their walls.
But now with the help of Conan's men and the money that he carries and gives to
them they are building those walls at a much faster clip.
And before the war is over the Athenians will once again be a walled city with a
walled port and with long walls connecting them.
In other words the bases for having an independent naval policy will be in place
thanks to Conan's victory on top of which he takes the Persian fleet and goes to
the Athenians and says it is now your fleet and suddenly the Athenians have
again probably the biggest fleet in the Greek world just like that.
Similarly or rather as a consequence of all this because for a while at least
they are able to dominate the Aegean Sea with these forces and with Conan around
they regain those famous islands that are so crucial to them.
The stepping stones to the Hellas Ponte Leno's embrace scare us become Athenian
owned again.
They also gain control of the sacred island of Apollo at Delors.
They also make an alliance with the important island of chaos.
And suddenly you have what are the just the bare beginnings of the
reconstruction of the old Athenian naval alliance.
You might want to call it an empire.
Let me make it very clear that even when they become far more powerful in years
to come they are never able to recreate the old Athenian Empire.
They never reached the point which was so decisive for their power where it is
truly an empire where almost every state in the league is contributing money
which allows the Athenians to not only build but to sustain in peacetime and
wartime.
The biggest navy and the best navy around.
They never get there.
They do become very important as a naval power again.
They are going to be a very significant state again.
But even though they are turning in that other direction they never get there.
But I think we need to remember that probably there's a very good chunk of the
Athenians who regard those days as the good old days and as the natural state of
things and is the place to which they ought to be going towards that empire.
Certainly a lot of their behavior in the Corinthian war and afterwards suggests
that that was a widespread opinion.
There was undoubtedly also hostility to that opinion as people look back on the
experience of what happened last time look at the look at the consequences.
There were important socio economic political significance of pursuing such a
policy.
It meant democracy.
That meant the naval democracy it meant the most extreme democracy and a lot of
people's memories especially those of the rich were of mistakes and defeats that
that democracy had brought about.
When you read Plato particularly about the Athenian democracy or even Aristotle
I think you have to remember that these people were very very critical of what
the Athenian democracy had done in the 5th century.
Blame the democracy for that defeat and then that was tied up with their
political views in general that democracy was a very bad wicked thing and that
that should help you understand this very strong bias against democratic
government on the part of such people
another special events in the course of the Corinthian war which would have some
consequence for greek life later on during that war.
There was a union between the cities of Corinth and Argos
it was brought about by a special emergency situation created by the war in
which all the fighting was around Corinth in which there was terrible
destruction of Corinthian property in which poverty came to be a problem.
Currency in a way that it had never been.
There was a topsy turvy situation.
It had been throughout the whole fifth century back into the sixth century an
oligarchic government a broad oligarchic government one that was widely thought
to be a good government and that so far as we know was never touched until
sometime here in the currency in war when these extreme conditions produced what
looks like a Democratic faction which seized power which murdered the leaders of
the opposition in a brutal way by the way on a holy day.
It was a memorable and horrible event.
So.
It was.
After that event had taken place that you see this union between our gods which
is a democracy and this democratic government in Corinth which is under siege
for the reasons that I've suggested
and what they do is they arrange for a new situation where citizens of one state
will be citizens of the other as well.
So theoretically if you lived in currents and you wanted to go to Argos to sit
in on the hour drive assembly you could do it and vice versa.
This is something absolutely new.
The idea of anything but a polis being by itself or being on top of other polls.
But the notion of there being a sharing of a regime Interpol's sharing of of
governmental responsibilities is really new and it becomes more usual in the
course of the next century and the century after that.
This one hardly lasts at all it's just a few years as a consequence of the war
and it's undone at the end of the war.
But it's an indication of what people might be thinking about and we shall see
that in the course of this century.
There will grow up federations that's something different.
But still it's the same thing.
In a way a federation is a political union that allows for the maintenance of
local powers on the part of the original members but also take some powers for a
central body which is made up of more than one.
We Americans of course have some idea about that but there was there was the
Arcadian league that came into being and the king league that came into being.
Being in the totally League which came into being and as a matter of fact our
founding fathers read very carefully about these experiments in federal
government as they were writing the American Constitution.
We have hard evidence about that the best evidence for those confederations does
not occur in our period it occurs later typically in the third and the second
centuries B.C. and the accounts of them are in the works of plebeians.
If you're ever interested so plebeian it was a very important figure for the
American.
Founding Fathers who wrote the Constitution but the first seed of this kind of
interstate cooperation on a basis that was not merely alliance but was co
citizenship is in the case of Corinth and August in the course of this war.
Well as the war dragged on.
It became clearer and clearer that neither side had any way of prevailing.
But another thing that happened that was to play a very important part in how
the war came to an end was that the Athenian control of the Sea was rapidly
making Athens stronger and stronger and more like that scary thing which Athens
had been to its neighbors and its opponents in the fifth century B.C..
Such that the Persians who after all had started the war by virtue of
encouraging the anti Spartan factions to get together and it had been supporting
it to some degree during the war and general began to feel that maybe Athens was
becoming more frightening from the Persian point of view than Sparta was after
all Sparta was out of the Navy business now and they were not likely to be able
to get back into it.
And if you don't have a navy you really can't threaten Persia very much.
So at least until Alexander came along and figured out a way to do it.
So
all of that gives the Spartans who really want to get out of this war because it
isn't going anywhere.
The the the the hope that they can bring about a peace and so the Spartans try
to make peace with the aid of Persia is a Spartan political figure by the name
of and Tacitus who emerges on this scene and we shall see it his life the few
times we hear about him.
He's always engaged in attempting to contain spark his ambitions to certainly
exclude the possibility of overseas commitments and I would argue I think most
guys would agree even to it's not to be engaged outside of the Peloponnese is
very far.
He seems to represent a traditionalist point of view which obviously comes to
the fore as this war which the Spartans have started really as part of a just
Alliance's aggressive policy isn't working.
The Spartans are having to constantly fight.
They are suffering casualties their allies are becoming more and more restive
and look what's happened.
Suddenly Sparta which was absolutely in charge of everything is practically on
the defensive.
So for all these reasons is opposition to the bold policy and touts it as
represents that he he gets the Spartan assembly or the Spartan Garcia and
efforts to support a mission to the king of Persia in which he tries to
negotiate a peace.
It doesn't work.
In large part because the enemies that is Athens and and Thebes particularly and
perhaps the others as well.
No I'm sorry.
Currents in Argos.
Also I'll tell you why in a moment are not ready to do what is necessary from
the Spartan point of view.
What the Spartans really want is to break up this coalition.
And all anti Spartan coalitions.
That's really the bottom line for Sparta.
No sense making peace if you leave these people in tact.
What's to stop the whole thing from happening again in the future.
That's the bottom line and they are unable to persuade the Greeks to make the
concessions that are necessary.
So the war continues and nothing really changes except things get worse.
This time the antacid is again negotiates a peace and he really negotiates it
with the great king of Persia.
The king of Persia has changed his mind about where the great threat comes from.
Threats of bullies in the three nineties in the latter part of the three
nineties engages in a series of naval campaigns all around the GNC in which he
covers one city after another that used to be under Athenian rule and once again
puts it under Athenian rule.
He even once again starts collecting money from them.
He did something also that the Athenians had done late in the Peloponnesian War.
He establishes a customs house in the hell a spot in the Bosphorus and every
ship that goes through pays a tax to the Athenians so there's a real feeling in
Persia obviously that these things are coming back to rebuild their empire and
we'd better stop them and the Spartans are safer.
From our point of view having been chastened by events and so I think that's
probably the single most important reason why the great king comes out and backs
and as we shall see insists on a peace in Greece which meets Spartans needs and
the needs are that all these international organizations should be broken up.
Obviously the the league of four states that have conducted the war must stop.
But on top of that the union between Argos and Corinth must be broken up.
That's especially critical to the Spartans.
That's right next door.
August would be strengthened by its association with currents and if it was
allowed to continue it would be a problem in the future so now to be broken up
seems of course was a great problem for the Spartans and they insisted that
before peace to come the Boche the thieves had the thieves had to give up their
control of the ocean.
They had used the war as an opportunity to reconstruct the old Ocean League
which left Thebes at the head and in control of the bulk of the ocean.
That was to be broken up in order to reduce and power originally.
The Spartans had wanted the Athenians to give up the things that they had
acquired in the course of the war but they couldn't do that.
Athens was still too strong in the one field that they couldn't be challenged in
easily.
Their control of the sea and so the compromise had to be made.
If a piece was to be made Athens would not join unless it was allowed to keep.
Let's not scare us Ambrose.
So that was permitted
so the peace came and it is.
The critical part Xenophon reports the exact language of a message that King
artic services sent to the Greeks.
That was in effect the instrument that made the peace.
Here's what it said.
King Ark.
Arctic circuses thinks it just that the cities in Asia and the islands of
classroom Meany and Cypress shall belong to him.
Further that all the other Greek cities small and great shall be autonomous.
Listen to that word that's critical that this piece is associated with the
principle of autonomy.
There shall be no breach of autonomy.
Except.
Says the king.
Let us Ambrose and scare us which shall belong to Athens as in the past.
If any refuse to accept this piece I shall make war on them along with those who
are of the same purpose.
Both by land and sea and with both ships and money.
Ancient writers and modern writers have disagreed as to what is the name of this
piece.
Some of them speak of the piece of an Tacitus.
More of them I think speak and I think they are right in this decision as the
King's piece.
This is not the product of a negotiation and the king is very careful even
though it really is.
But he is very careful to make it clear that that's not the way he sees it.
This is a command level by the King at the Greek say saying this is how you will
be.
I say so.
And if you don't like it I will beat the hell out of you.
That's the message that comes but of course the reason he can say that with as
much confidence as he does is that his partner in the peace is Sparta.
This is a peace that will benefit Persia and benefit Sparta at the expense of
everybody else.
The Spartans take it as a license to run Greece in the way that they see fit.
Notice nobody says that the Spartans have to break up the Peloponnesian league.
That doesn't count as any kind of a violation of autonomy.
And so that's the nature of the peace when among the results are that the
Asiatic Greeks are abandoned by the Greek people by the Greek states once and
for all.
And of course that means Sparta mainly until finally Alexander will impose his
rule when he conquers the Persian Empire to be ocean league is dissolved all
gross and currents are split and Athens loses all that has been gained except
for those three islands that are mentioned
Sparta regains and in a certain sense gets greater control of the mainland Greek
situation.
It is the heads your moan of Greece now as a kind of a partner of the great king
and the Great King leaves Greece essentially to the Spartans without any
interference.
How do you do that.
They do that in the same way they did it to win the Peloponnesian War.
An enemy of the Spartans would say because they were me die Zeus.
They had done the work of the Persians they had collaborated with the Persians
against the Greeks.
That's not how the Spartans saw it of course they would have said something like
I guess there's a crack in Plutarch somewhere.
It said We have not meet eyes.
It's the Spartan.
It's the Persians who have Spartan eyes but that's a very kind way of looking at
it.
It is without question.
If you look back on it we're talking about just about one hundred years after
the Persian War and it's a reversal of the Persian Wars the Greeks won the
Persian Wars and the proof of it was they chased the great king out of Europe
eager to stay alive and completely unable to do anything about what the Greeks
were to do with the coastal regions of the Persian Empire.
Now the king of Persia is telling the Greeks what they must do.
It was widely seen seen as a cause for great shame and by those people who were
not friendly to Sparta.
A great.
A great core cause of anger against the Spartans who were responsible for this
condition of things.
But the Spartans didn't care much because they were now in a position to
exercise the power that the dominant force in Sparta who was just Elias and his
supporters wanted to do so in three eighty five.
We see the Spartans attacking the city of Manzanita once again the story is very
much like this story of Ellis and forward to this time Manzanita had been again
one of those states in the Peloponnese that had joined in a quadruple alliance
against Sparta and twenty one.
The great battle that so much threatened Spartan existence and for a team had
been fought on the territory of Manta.
It had a democratic history and democratic tendencies.
So with no group no pretext really at all.
The Spartans invaded their territory besiege the city managed finally to to
defeat Manzanita by sending a diverting the waters of a river that ran through
Manzanita to the point where it undermined the walls and they had to surrender
Xenophon learns an important lesson about warfare in this event and he concludes
his account of this by saying Well that shows you that you should not build your
city around the river so any of you are planning.
Keep that in mind.
Then soon afterwards the Spartans turn on another city in the Peloponnese as the
city of fliers which is not to this it's the southwest of Corinth.
Not a very big city but not a small tiny one either.
And what it turns out here is that the
thing that the fly agents have done that the Spartans don't like is that they
have been a democracy for part of the time and.
King is just the latest basically removes the government after fighting a war
and besieging the city was not an easy task.
It was expensive and time consuming but they finally do establish if they do
gain a victory and it just always puts in a new government made up not just of
oligarchs which of course they were.
But they were the personal friends of adjusts the less.
If you look at it historically it resembles the stuff that like lasagna was
doing at the end of the Peloponnesian War and afterwards in placing these deck
car keys of his friends in the cities so that they would not be only pro Spartan
but pro life Sander.
And here are just the latest did the same thing in fly us.
And it's not the only place that he did.
And then a Normandy followed enormity as the Spartan power was unchecked in this
period of time.
Up in the north.
The city of Linz us in the Chao civic Peninsula was gaining control of that
peninsula basically establishing itself as the hedge hormonal power over cities
in that region and 383 a couple of cities up in that region came to Sparta
complaining of what the cleansings were doing and urging the Spartans to defend
them and to undo these things using as the basis for their appeal.
The Kings peace.
This was a violation of their autonomy.
The Spartans were to be the upholders of Greek autonomy according to the king's
peace.
And so they ought to send a force up and the Spartans did so.
And in the course of that war which lasted from three eighty two to three
seventy nine.
They defeated alliances dissolve the Confederacy and destroyed any again any
notion of a league other than the Spartan league.
But there was an event that was connected with that movement up towards the
north east up to the Charles citizen which was the most famous.
I think there's a small competition for a couple of events but one of the most
famous anyway in this period illustrating the arrogance and power of the
Spartans had Germany a Spartan force was sent off ostensibly to reinforce their
Spartan army up there in the Charles cities C.
It was led by a general named Phebe das.
As he was moving north on a route that would not have been the normal route to
take a route that took him right past the city of thieves he camped out at night
and on his way there was contacted by an important official in the government of
thieves an oligarch a friend of Sparta.
The next day the Spartan army seized the Acropolis of Thebes which is called
Academy a
they did so on the day a sacred day a holiday was being celebrated everybody was
in the same shape.
People are on on a holiday.
Nobody was ready to.
They took the city.
The enemies of the dominant party that had invited the Spartans in were put to
death if they could not flee successfully.
The Spartans left.
A garrison on the Kashmir and took control of the city and had their stooges run
the city thereafter.
Now this had not been determined by the Spartan assembly.
This was not the consequence of a policy decision that the Spartan officials or
people had made.
When feebleness came back to Sparta he was put on trial.
And there was great anger against him and there was great anger against him
against part of course throughout the Greek world.
There was no real case for him.
But surprisingly enough even though he was not a member of a just alliances
faction I just always got up at the trial and simply said You guys are all
talking about the wrong thing.
There's only one question that should be asked about the behavior of it as.
Did what he did was what was what he did good or bad for Sparta
Well it was obviously good.
Why in the world you want to punish him.
And he was not punished with any severity.
A mild fine or at least a fine was imposed.
We don't know if he ever paid it.
In any case the critical thing was what would Sparta do about the action itself
the fact that it had in the garrison up there on the cat Mia.
If they thought it had been the wrong thing to do if it had been the idea of
feed it asked and what didn't represent Spartan policy they should have
withdrawn the garrison the garrison stayed so that Spartan now this was
something that rang all around the Greek world.
This was the worst thing anybody could remember in peacetime with no allegation
of cause they had simply seized another city an ancient city a great city and
they refused to back off
finally there's one other.
Example of this same kind of behavior the government concedes was tyrannical
imposed upon an unwilling people.
Some of the people who had fled it would did a reverse of what had happened in
the time of the 30 tyrants in Athens they fled to Athens and of course many
Athenians gave them support and protected them.
And then in 379 a small number of these exiles launched a clever plot that
allowed them to sneak in to
Thebes and to make their way to the cat Mia and to kill the oligarchic leaders
of the city in the dark when nobody could really do anything about it and to
drive away a number of the Spartans and to free the city
Thebes became free it became democratic too because these people now belong to a
Democratic faction and more and more if you're a Democrat or anti Spartan.
If you're an oligarch you're pro Spartan and so all of this is the beginning of
what we will get through next time which is the flowering of Theeb and power.
It's going to happen as they get stronger and stronger.
But the event I wanted to.
Mention as the twin of the CBS thing is that in three seventy nine a Spartan.
Ha most of one of the garrisons in the ocean by the name of Squadron ass took a
force by night marched into Attica ostensibly.
His plan was to reach the Paris and then that would allow them to take control
of Athens because they could cut them off from their Port at the sea.
He didn't get it quite right.
By the time morning broke and they were visible he was still miles and miles and
miles away from the Paris and so all he could do was to do some harm to the
Athenian territory and then to go home.
But when he got home again he hadn't gotten any vote from the Spartan assembly
or from the accuracy of the efforts to do anything.
Another thing that he'd apparently done on his own so there was another trial.
And
this time the only thing he had going for him apparently.
Well he still had a just delays his general approach.
But he was the lover of the son of a justice Elias and so we just last who
ostensibly was hostile to what had happened was made to speak in his defense and
this time his argument was simply Sparta has too few men of quality to be able
to execute any for whatever reason whatsoever.
And so we shouldn't do anything to spidery ass so they didn't and that was yet
another signal that it had fantastic consequences in Athens.
They had been holding some Spartan ambassadors when the when this Rodrigues raid
had taken place and they were holding them in effect as hostages.
But the Hartleys these Spartans said look we had nothing to do with it.
This was strategy as did it on his own he'll certainly be condemned when he gets
back to Sparta.
So this is it OK you can go home and then he wasn't.
And so the Athenians now would determine that they would have to fight Sparta
and in the process they set about organizing an alliance general alliance meant
against Sparta which they were able to do in considerable part because of all of
the irritation that had been felt all around Greece by these terrible actions of
the Spartans.
And as I think I'll tell you next time they put together what we call the second
Athenian confederation and they made an alliance with the newly liberated Thebes
Thebes which is going to get stronger and stronger and stronger.
And so we have now a threat once again to the Spartan hegemony which will be
very serious but of a different kind from the one we had before.
I'll you that next time.